les réunions chez w9 mais reconnaît
perdu les droits de diffusion pour les
simpson
chez lucasfilm
non non il ya 6 star wars il n'y aura
pas de septième film il y aura un
septième film je viens d'avoir l'idée
il y aura même une trilogie à les
apaiser
comme chez m6 on diffuse quoi ce soir
top chef
top chef l'after top chef que sont ils
devenus ouais top chef jean et norbert
le défi japon qu'est ce qu'on fait pour
l'iphone 6 on améliore la batterie on
peut faire la reconnaissance digitale
mais derrière téléphone la batterie on
pourrait le temps peut faire un écran 3d
sinon aurait un écran 3d c'est très bien
de batteries seront utiles et son fils
james et observe que les gendarmes aient
way est prochaine alors pour l'année
prochaine je vais penser à pékin express
soit pékin express l'after eight présent
mais région défi ouais
chez les hauts de nîmes nous la réunion
que commencer quoi ce bordel qu'est ce
que tu attends quoi qu'est-ce qu'il ya
quatre mois
c'est quoi ce match là on me dit pour le
mas moi je prends membres s'étaient mis
d'accord il m'avait envoyé ménages
d'accord on n'a peut-être pas envoyé de
bombay en fait c'est le galaxy ace au
galaxy note aux plus gros oui
neuville à l'eau non désolé oui je sais
mais chez les anonymes aussi nous allons
vous pirater mais non mais non
jeanneau 10 j'avoue avoir piraté couture
saison derrick
vous allez recevoir une lettre au nom
pas une lettre et une lettre no chez
disneyland faut optimiser les entre eux
par une nouvelle campagne de pub
peut-être mais une nouvelle campagne
chez nintendo maison bien la wii ou la
wii ware elle a cartonné
non la wiiu notre nouvelle console avec
la lettre e à fin mai la lettre lui
n'existe pas si je ne vois aucun
document qui mentionne la wiiu
chez playstation comment ils ben bella
ou août marge la plus vite à chez sony
music mais qu on a retrouvé un orange
demande michael jackson s'est acheté du
lait troisième liste de courses à penser
génial ça on en faire un album chez
spotify voire jamais je vous présente
jean louis qui donne chez deezer il n'a
pas écrit citer ici - est d'ailleurs à
flamme changer de spots là le spot
l'alleud spotify je vois qu'on mène pas
large que de chemin allez vas crever
chez sony music et ouvert à tous aux
abris
c'est peut-être chez facebook
on va mettre de la pub là et là et la la
la la la la la la la la la
chez mcdo ça c'est une photo du nouveau
big mac ce matin mais les bruits trop
beau c'est bon on s'en fout c'est la
même chose tu es sabah c'est une photo
de ma femme que se fait la belle ah oui
tiens voilà justement chez facebook
c'est zuckerberg faisait vraiment
racheter l'oculus pour 2 milliards
ouais il faudrait racheter du papier là
pour la photocopieuse parce que tenir
service du papier comme vraiment ça va
bien chez mm
chez sony pictures c'est l'histoire de
peter parker qui fait mordre par une
araignée du coup ils dénoncent cependant
même si moi j'ai fait trois films sur
spider man
ah non pas du tout c'est amazing spider
man ah oui ah oui ça va être un super
film un max de thune je vais pour moi je
sers iota chez allociné vous avez vu
michel dans la séquence d'avants et une
perche en aurait bien vu michel -
humaines vous avez pas vu michel nowak
en prendre plus
michèle chay watts et pas mal de vidéos
non c'est la pub 1 chez dailymotion
elle a fait de son but j'ai dit mme diop
like vous êtes embauché vous êtes à noël
responsable commercial non no light vous
êtes mon assistant du coup une couche
ensemble
oui bon champagne chez bein pourra
commencer comment booster les
inscriptions campagne de pub brassage
avait un accent so foot un excellente
idée de pousser à la mine sont pas
chypre bieber 50 millions de
téléchargements super on supprime
évidemment au champagne chez champagne
chez vous yvon dandurand champagne ouais
je préfère la première vidéo chez moi va
terminer tous nos gags par schumann
chiffré remettre
concernant youtube
chihuaha à hasnon encore une pub chez
snapshot une petite vidéo et annonça en
réunion la réunion
et chez disneyland abonne toi
non non à aa